call to order the meeting of the Health
and Human Services oversight committee
for Friday March 24
2023 welcome to everyone
and would the clerk please call the roll
representative Pearson here
representative McDonald here
representative Weber here representative
Edwards not here representative King
here representative Merchant here
representative Murphy uh here
representative or I'm sorry Senator gray
uh senator avard avard
and Senator Rosenwald
um
excuse me but uh representative Makai
is he part of this committee
or is he just
he has something he'd like to say so he
is not on the committee well
but we value his great wisdom of course
we do sir thank you
next on the agenda is the minutes from
February 24th I wish to thank the clerk
I like to look at minutes
and say oh yeah that's what we did and
it gives us good information so thank
you so much are there any questions that
need to be asked of the clerk or any
proposed suggested changes
movement second
all right moved and seconded any further
discussion any uh inaccuracies
abstain representative Merchant
I was not I was not here at the 24th
like two so it looks perfect to you good
seeing nothing uh by way of suggested
Corrections all in favor of accepting
the minutes I I opposed thank you
interim commissioner Lori Weaver for our
monthly update thank you
good morning
it prepared an update for you focused
primarily on Behavioral Health
happenings this week and the week before
excuse me
you may or may not be aware that on
Wednesday of this week at governor and
Council the department uh received full
support from the council to pursue a
contract with solution health and this
will increase our
okay Acuity beds for the state so we
will have a total of 120 beds in that
hospital so that will bring a net gain
of 44 additional adult drf beds 13 gyro
psych beds and 24 Youth and Adolescent
beds so
solution help will be taking their
existing beds that they have and then
taking these new beds and putting them
all into the new facility so the
expectation is that those beds or that
hot the hospital I think by the end of
24 beginning of 25 is the expected date
for that so that was a long time
in the process to get that contract
through so we're quite pleased and the
time is of essence because we're using
for the capital defrayment costs we're
using 15 million of Opera funds so we
have really very little time to make
sure the money is encumbered and then
also that by December of 26 that the all
the money is spent but we are remaining
positive that that will happen so that
was a big win I think in terms of trying
to build some additional capacity as we
all know capacity is an issue not just
on the front end but also on the back
end
any question do you want me to just keep
going
let's just see if there's any questions
on that that is indeed a big win
representative King
yeah for the minutes I just wanted to
make sure which which hospital a
solution help solution Health thank you
representative Weber and could you give
us the numbers a bit The increased
numbers of beds again because I didn't
get quite a whole of those down sure
um so it was a total of um the total is
120 with the net gains are 44 dealt uh
13 of the jarrow psych okay and then 24
for the Youth and Adolescent that's it
okay thank you very much
this
um
I assume is the the victory part of the
loss we incurred when the plan for
something in around Epping didn't happen
is this the replacement for that didn't
going not going forward yeah we had two
interested parties the other party was
HCA and then we did we were not able to
move forward with haca come to any sort
of agreement so but we were with
solution health so yes okay good thank
you
yes anything else
representative Weber and could you
remind me where this is sure the
location has not yet been announced part
of the was the vendor waiting to make
sure the contractor was going to be
approved I do know that there are three
locations that they've scoped out and
once they had approval they were going
to start to move on that so they're not
starting from scratch they are just yeah
it'll be Southern New Hampshire uh
probably Manchester area
is one of those if you are able to say
uh is one of those
um
pamstead on the grounds of Hampstead
Hospital no no okay
there's only so much I've got something
else I know I yeah live right there
um yeah yes go ahead I would just put a
plug in to be more towards Manchester or
the middle of the state as opposed to
all the way over in the Southeast Corner
as somebody who comes from the southwest
corner of the state sure I think we've
been pretty clear with the vendor in
terms of where the needs are I mean
ultimately it's going to be their
decision but an availability of course
but yes got it thank you representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair
um so I'm just curious of the three
sites is the current site where the city
center is located there's so much land
there would that be a possible siding
location I don't know if it's a possible
sighting location it's as I understand
it's not one of them I don't have a lot
of information on the location we were
not privy to that I was just told that
they had three locations that they were
looking at right thank you
okay
carry on right so uh our psychiatric
residential treatment facility at
Hampstead Has Broken Ground for
construction I believe at the end of
last week I was out there at the
beginning of this week and was able to
see the wing that they are converting
and it's in pretty good shape so I'd say
that within probably the next six weeks
that will be complete it may be sooner
but I'll just go with six weeks and at
that point uh we'll be they've hired
staff to uh critical staff not all the
staffs to begin the programming and once
the construction is complete admit
children
I was out there a week before you and
was very impressed with both the work
there are doing facility wise but also
the vision they had would you for the
group distinguish between the existing
unit and the new one in terms of any
program differences well the sure the
the prtf really is a step down from the
high acute care that the the current
facility has all of its beds designated
at this would be a step down so this
could be youth or adolescents that
aren't quite ready to discharge to home
or even yet to a community residential
site so they would step down here they
would have more flexibilities than they
did in an inpatient setting so they
would have safety they would have a case
management system that wraps around them
while they're there but the whole idea
is to be able to get them to transition
out back as soon as possible so it's
it's a nice step down it's also a
service we don't have so we send a lot
of our kids out of state right now for
that so when that it arises the hope is
that we're able to take care of that
need within the state and not have to
send kids out of state and keep them
close to their families
thank you
the other good news about a week and a
half ago New Hampshire was awarded a
samsa grant for working on some we were
one of 15 states to be awarded the samsa
grant which is basically looking at our
community mental health system and
basically putting in some supports there
to really look at how services are
delivered so one of the key components
of that was addressing co-occurring
issues of mental health and substance
use disorder that integrated Approach at
that level the goal is to reduce Ed
visits and Ed readmissions expanding the
cmhc infrastructure and capacity so
things like Workforce
issues payment methodologies and systems
so there's as I understand that there's
several CM cmhcs now that are already
working towards us so this allows us
some money and time to be able to help
them be successful to set up that model
so we're pretty proud that we were
awarded that Grant and I think it'll be
another step into an enhancement into
our Behavioral Health System my bet is
the clerk would like to know what samsa
means
you would be right
I
I know some of the acronyms
Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services
Association
Administration and a
too many acronyms
so exactly what are the initials oh
substance abuse SSU
um
abuse s-a-n-h
-s a
got it
I wasn't actually that far
services
thank you thank you
and I if I can move on to I have two
other quick updates um also at
Wednesday's council meeting we received
approval to add five additional drf beds
to Dartmouth Hitchcock so again it's an
existing facility
um that will be adding five additional
drf Beds which will help some of the
demand that we have one of the things
that I I didn't mention with the
solution Health contract but is relevant
to both contracts is they both have
requirements to serve a minimum of
Medicaid population so for solution
Health it's 30 percent of the population
served should be Medicaid as well as
Dartmouth is actually 40 percent
so solution health I think is currently
operating around 34 percent of serving
that population anyways so there's a
guarantee that we're going to make sure
that the folks that need the services
are able to get them
and the last
well not the last update but we did have
a pretty successful floor Amendment
yesterday for HB 49 for Our Youth
Services Center we're quite uh happy
about this in terms of it allows us the
work to move forward there's a lot of
work to be done as I'm sure everyone is
aware in terms of the model developing
the model getting the site selection and
then working towards building a new
facility so we're not going to get ahead
of ourselves but we are going to get the
work done that we need to get done in
the appropriate time so yesterday was a
very a good day for those serving
children youth and families with this
facility kudos to representative Edwards
it was a team effort if Mr ribson hadn't
done what he had done it never would
have happened
yes director ribson was very critical
but so were you as well I agree it was a
team approach and I think it was a good
good approach of all stakeholders
and I would just say we're in the middle
of budget as you probably all know in
the middle of the halfway through the
legislative session so we are humming we
are quite busy lots happening still a
lot of work to get done and all of these
other things happening too so
we have a lot of work and not enough
people to do it I will still make that
plug
however the good news is that our
vacancy rate has dropped a little bit
since the last time I saw you I believe
I told you it was 22.3 and now this uh
at this point I think at the end of last
week we're down to 19 so it's not a huge
draw but it is trending in the right
direction and the goal is to try to keep
it trending down
so a good week
would you care to say a few words
speaking of uh representative Edwards he
is the one that introduced me to the
military term after Action Report
um
we used to just go let's all sit down
and see what we did wrong but I like his
term much better and we're going to be
doing that over a period of time would
you care to say a few words to that sure
I spoke with director Buxton this
morning so director Buxton is for
Homeland Security emergency management
he's the director the after action
report that we would do would be with
FEMA and the funding would come through
hsem and would be a contract was
actually approved this past Wednesday at
the council to get that work done so
that is driven from
from procuring the work is from hsem
however the after action report of what
we did right and what we could do better
will involve all the stakeholders all
the players everybody that was a part of
that response team so director Buxton
has told me that he will be getting me
at least a high level of what the next
steps are and I had mentioned that there
was a desire from this committee to hear
more so we want to be able to provide
something that's meaningful for you
probably not next month but maybe as we
get closer to the summer
he'll have we'll have more information
on that
as you and I had spoken previously to to
my way of thinking there is the
department there is the legislature and
there's the general public and all three
of those things swirl around in various
ways during a pandemic and there was
some creative
interface during the pandemic that
perhaps we could learn from and
establish not rigidly but establish as
kind of General ways to go forward for
when the next one hits I've been
recommending and a couple of you have
actually started reading the book the
psychology of the pandemics by Stephen
Taylor and if you just read the book
without reading the introduction which
several of my high school teachers said
one must never do
but if you did you would read through
the book and probably conclude with two
glaring errors
this was a tremendous retrospective on
the recent pandemic then if you read the
forward you'd realize it was nothing of
the sort this book was written two years
before covid uh it was a scholarly as
psychological and sociological
understanding of reactions of
individuals people groups officials
organizations and so on to pandemics
with special reference to the 1918-19
flu epidemic but also Ebola and various
of the recent many pandemics
I think in terms of how
departments and legislators and the
general public interface I found this to
be tremendously helpful
um
I can put names to categories he's
talking about in here just from having
lived it as a legislator but also as the
executive director of a small Medical
Center and how we approach it from that
perspective with our patients so this is
a plea if I don't get anything for this
I should have negotiated that ahead of
time but the book is the psychology of
pandemic Stephen Taylor and if we're
going to have a little little tease next
time and a much bigger report the times
after that this would be something we
would all do well to read and reread but
I'm very much looking forward to to this
because there'll be another one soon
I'm afraid hopefully not for a little
while
after I've retired from the legislature
I think and
representative McKay will have to keep
it going for us
anything else
for the commissioner
saying nothing thank you so much support
like to call up Henry Lipman for the uh
update in terms of Medicaid uh heard
some good things coming out of the
Senate this week would you update us
good morning thank you for the record
Henry Littman and
um I sent you uh what the abbreviation
for samhsa is so that could be forwarded
to the clerk
so that's exactly right okay good and I
appreciate that thank you
um
so I had shared with you on the dental
front that we have received all the
necessary legislative requirements with
respect to state plan amendments which
there were like four or five of those
and several waivers uh
um as well as an 11 15 waiver to be able
to fall within the prescribed design
particularly around cost sharing and
limitations on who receives uh dentures
and the like
and uh
in terms of the network development
that's progressing we're we're I think
good to start on April 1st in fact
there'll be a van in um both Concord and
Colebrook to help people with
eligibility or even to provide some
um
some dental services to members
potentially on that Saturday and again
they'll be in Concord in Colebrook so
we're getting the sort of the middle and
the the top of the state
and things are just coming together on
that it was a very fast uh time frame to
stand it up from the time the
legislation has passed it may not seem
like that was fast but it was very fast
and we had full cooperation from CMS in
terms of understanding what the
legislative intent was to help us get it
done in time
um
in terms of this the the Senate Bill 263
um as you know it
um Mr chair can can I ask a question
about the dental program before yeah
before we go past Dental Programs go
ahead okay
you guys have done fantastic work on
getting this program stood up I'm really
glad that we got the waivers in place
that was the only thing that was causing
me to lose sleep so so thank you now I
can go back to sleep uh I I can you can
you quantify or describe a little more
of the status of the provider Network do
we do we have glaring holes somewhere
that we should be concerned about
I think that we're still working that I
don't have a quantitative answer for you
today
um but we in terms of being able to
um
lockdowns the essential care that if
someone's having a dental emergency and
and some preventative care I think we're
in a strong enough position to to launch
um I think I could certainly provide a
written update by the end of the month
because that's when you know the
Contracting of people is sort of
sometimes a last minute activity we're
still working on it very hard and Delta
Dental out of their own
capitation amount is is adding some
incentives to try to fill some of the
holes that that that exist but
definitely we can give you a map of that
and and uh so so since you started with
filling in holes I want to drill into
this a little bit deeper thank you
what are the capabilities of these
mobile Dental Vans are do they have any
portable x-ray in them for example do
they you know what what what what level
of care can be provided
the straight answer is I am not fully
aware of that I've
um Dr Finney who's had to be out of town
today could have helped me with that
answer but um I can Circle back with you
with an email next week
also on Dental I'd be just I'd be really
encouraged a little update on in the
last couple of months how many Dental
students have entered into an agreement
with us for a reduction on their tuition
loans in exchange for service I know
when I last spoke with Delta Dental this
is something they do I just you know if
somebody gets hey we got two more last
month that would really make me feel
happy
if we did I will uh Sarah knows that
information I apologize I just don't
but we'll get it to you thank you
anything else on Dental
yes
I had two things one of which is I'm
trying to remember who I was talking to
who uh was saying that there was a
program you know we have all these loan
forgiveness programs and you have to
work X number of years and
uh somebody I think at our County
meeting was talking about a program
where
each month
you get a stipend that covers your loan
payment and it just made a penny drop
for me because
when something goes wrong and something
sometimes does go wrong you know either
somebody's already paid the loans up
front loses the person they thought they
were going to have or somebody who
thought their loans were going to be
repaid has gotten three quarters of the
way and then loses
the repayment and this just takes care
of it on a month by month basis and
you're always building up an incentive
for the employee to stay because it's
being taken care of and I just wanted to
throw that out because I just thought it
was brilliant and I never thought of it
before
but the other thing I just wanted to say
was congratulations because this has
been a long time coming and and
really appreciated that we're getting to
the day
thank you and um I'm sure to bring that
back to the staff please do very hard to
make this happen
um and I can follow up on all these
three or four issues and
before we get too long in the tooth yeah
I had to do that for representative
Edwards he opened it up
oh God
please continue so I think the on the
agenda was uh
what was going on with the granite
Advantage Healthcare program and the
Senate took a policy vote I think people
are aware of 24 to zero and then um how
Senate Finance this week uh uh passed uh
seven to nothing
um in finance committee
um and I don't know the senator the
chairman would like to add any color to
that uh or not uh certainly
certainly the the Senate to
overwhelmingly supported it yesterday
it was not a table thing so that it will
go to the house
and I hope that the House
Representatives in here will be able to
uh to Shepherd it through
and I don't know if representative
Edwards would um uh would like to speak
to what division three did uh this week
on on that but there's a a house
position from division three I guess
will be considered uh next week is that
right uh representative division three
is now all done with its work they're
doing the the last of our bills uh and
then finance will vote on them I think
everything out on Monday officially so
till Monday it's all just uh what what
cement
but what cement though does have uh does
have a reauthorization
um of two years it also it clarifies a
little bit more or
um the issue of the transition from the
hospital
donations uh to the liquor fund which is
what the Senate position is as well
that's just taking a credit for the
period in which the donation still is in
place
but the really the the main difference
is whether it's you know permanent
reauthorization or or some other period
I had raised with the
the committee the concern about what
impacted potentially a two-year could
have on our procurement of the new MCO
contract which is will be effective
September 1 of 24. um and I'm sure that
will be considered at some point in time
representative Edwards so so what the
division three did was we tried to
anticipate exactly what the Senate
version was and we took it you know
comma for comma and we ended up putting
a two-year suspense on it instead of
permanent reauthorization if it were me
and I didn't have to worry about anyone
else I think I would make a six-year
authorization so that you would have
time to do a normal five-year contract
but so we're we there's still work to be
done
thank you
um and I guess the uh that there are any
other questions on on the ex Medicaid
expansion Grant Advantage Health Care
Program I guess the other uh key thing
happening is you know I went through a
report last month with the committee on
the unwind if you will that's actually
in motion now and I think don't have a
lot to say today about it because
people still have opportunities till the
end of the month but I think when I if
you invite me back next month I will
I'll have some information to share
there but I think all things considered
it's it's uh it's moving pretty well at
this point
anything else
that's all I have for today anything but
Mr Lipman
thank you thank you
advisory Council and child care annual
report Marianne barter and Karen
a bear
we had a road dedicated to a cornoyer
the other day and I leaned over to a
francophone near me and said I grew up
in a Massachusetts Mill Town that's
cornwaya and he agreed but
I guess
good morning Karen Hebert director for
the division of economic stability for
the Department of Health and Human
Services
hi I'm Marianne barter I'm the chair of
the New Hampshire Child Care advisory
Council
heard we'd like me too
so the child care advisory Council
exists to inform the state and
legislative leaders on
um situations that would impede child
care in the state impede both the growth
of child care the availability of it and
the affordability of it and certainly
the last few years have been challenging
in all of these ways I'll say that the
child care advisory Council in the past
has met every other month and now we're
meeting bi-weekly because there is just
so much happening in the field we've
worked very closely with our state
Partners to come up with a plan to
improve Child Care Systems in the state
moving forward
and it's a good plan it's a very strong
plan that we hope gets funded and will
help us make sure that there's
availability of child care moving
forward I will say that one of our
biggest concerns in the field is the
wages Child Care wages are
extraordinarily low and they always have
been but unfortunately now
we are we are about to be the lowest
paid industry in the country according
to the hunt Institute so the reason why
that's becoming such an issue now is
because so many other fields pay better
and so post pandemic if you perhaps had
to choose between child care and Target
or Child Care Dunkin Donuts they would
pay about the same in child care is a
much more enriching way to spend your
day unfortunately now the pay
differential is significant enough that
many people are choosing Dunkin Donuts
or Target over child care so the child
care advisory Council list has convened
a group to look at wages look at funding
for increasing wages Statewide to look
at what other states are doing to meet
to address this issue and to make sure
that we put our New Hampshire spin on
what other states are doing New
Hampshire is a very unique place and
solutions that work other places will
not necessarily work here so we want to
make sure that we continue to be the
workforce for the workforce and support
our business Community Statewide
Miss Hebert
thank you and I'm happy to be here with
Miss barter we've been working very
closely with the child care advisory
Council particularly in the last couple
of years to develop the child care
strengthening plan as a result of the
2022 Senate Bill 446 direct to the
department to come up with sustainable
long-term solutions that would
strengthen the child care industry in
New Hampshire and also increase its
capacity so we did put together a plan
working very closely with the council
and for a number of months to put
together that plan which had been
submitted last of June
to the uh to the legislature and to the
governor's office
so we're been looking at a number of
initiatives that we are moving forward
with in that particular plan but I would
highlight the number of initiatives we
have going on in the what's known as the
arpa discretionary plan and I left you
copies of that particular plan the
status report of that plan right now
because there are a number of
initiatives there that you know we are
moving forward with we have funding with
uh that we are a number of initiatives
that are in development now to help this
industry
I'm also pleased to uh
to let you know that just as of
yesterday afternoon gopher did Awards
the department 3.6 million dollars
specifically from the child care
strengthening plan uh for the purposes
of providing one-time grants to the
child care providers
to help reduce operating costs overhead
costs so that they could increase wages
and support the workforce so there's one
particular initiative moving forward
that would help the workforce there's a
lot more work that needs to be done
there is not one single solution that is
going to strengthen this particular
industry I'm very happy that the council
is moving forward with their Workforce
meetings and hopefully we will have
better information going forward
including any particular research and
data that could come out of those
meetings in order to make some
improvements there so thank you
representative King
thank you actually representative Weber
beat me but uh I'll take it
um
my first thought was uh on this whole
Child Care issue that we have is uh our
business is the New Hampshire businesses
being asked how they might solve this uh
with their own employees or offering
this as a way to attract employees and
then I noticed on page three that
there's something about business and
child care partnership is are they
linked
so yes we have business partners who are
very engaged in this process and they
acknowledge that child care Workforce
will be needed in order for them to have
their own employees having and I'm
actually an executive director of a
child care facility that has a
relationship with two different
businesses that do that they give us
free space and then we provide child
care for their employees and it does cut
down on the cost somewhat I think the
amounts that we were talking about when
we're talking about supporting Child
Care are so staggeringly high that it is
going to have to be a multi-prong
approach so there might be some support
to the business Community can offer us
but I'm not sure I don't know the
affordability of
of that moving forward and how much
Financial investment they're going to be
able to give us or be willing to give us
um it's essential though it is a huge
sum of money I mean when we our
estimates are somewhere in the 30
million dollar range for increasing
Child Care wages and
um Karen was
share the wonderful news about gopher
which is phenomenal news I mean we are
excited about that initiative and we're
excited to see it move forward but my
payroll is 1.2 million dollars a year so
you can see that 3.6 million and I'm
just one moderate size Center so you can
see where
um
3.6 million dollars is a huge amount of
money and we're excited to have it it's
probably not going to make a huge impact
on my my wages
representative Weber
thank you and that leads right into my
question which is um
when we say reducing overhead costs are
we talking weatherization are we talking
computers that will help you do billing
more efficiently what exactly are we
talking about with respect to that money
thank you for the question so that could
be anything from an outstanding mortgage
or perhaps a long-term lease or rental
payments even buying property that would
reduce the
um the expenditures that you have it
could also be anything such as deferred
repairs and maintenance that a provider
has or
expanding programs expanding their
outdoor or creating an outdoor
setting that's appropriate for children
great thank you
and I also wanted to answer your
question too with respect to the
business Improvement project the also
the business and child care partnership
program that we are
developing we've just released an RFP
for the business Improvement project so
that is underway and the the intent
behind that is to really be able to
conduct Health assessments with the
providers and address really
specifically what it is that each of
them may particularly need that would
strengthen their particular
Center or provider setting so we'll end
up matching them with the Professionals
in whatever it is that comes out of
their particular Health assessment and
then they'll be able to apply for grants
in order to support whatever their need
may be going forward
the partnership program is also
something that's pretty new and and
Innovative actually for the child care
industry as Miss barter was describing
that you know really this child care
does support
all other Industries and in order to
support their Workforce Child Care
Workforce needs to be supported and
strengthened so the partnership program
is really exactly that it's working with
the employer Community to try to have
those conversations come up with other
innovative ideas moving forward how can
we can work together to solve the
problems in child care today so that we
know that families would have access to
affordable child care across the state
not just in your traditional hours but
non-traditional hours as well we have of
course a number of Industries in New
Hampshire that work second and third
shift
we want to be able to support those
families as well as much as we can
representative Weber
well it's a little surprised to hear you
say that this is a New Concept because
my my
anecdotal understanding and it's just
one or two or three places in various
parts of the state was that some of
these programs had existed for quite
some time and just as you said the costs
got to the point where the businesses
could not sustain their contributions
and and I'm thinking maybe an HTI had a
program and they had to give it up and I
think it was taken over by a provider
but not sure don't know what the status
is now but
um
I'm I'm
concerned about the fact that we're
actually currently we're going in the
wrong direction on that and I'm hoping
that this is a turnaround
excuse me I absolutely I know exactly
what you're saying
um having more people involved in having
businesses create Child Care programs
are probably not going to be the
solution that is probably not going to
do it okay it's just too expensive and
child care is sort of crazy I mean if
you look at our budgets they do not make
sense somehow we make it work but it it
is a very very tight margin I think what
Miss Hebert was saying what the support
may be having the conversations about
how can we lower your overhead how could
we as a business perhaps could purchase
spaces from you so those spaces are
available when we have staff who need to
have child care needs
um I know there's been some
conversations with DHHS about purchasing
spaces for protective children because
right now children who are in protective
services are not guaranteed Child Care
spaces because there just are not enough
available so those sort of innovative
relationships I think will probably be
the future of business and child care
partnership ships okay so it's a
changing model it's a changing model yes
representative Merchant thank you Mr
I find it kind of ironic that the real
benefit to child care to a large degree
is the business community
yeah what I'm struggling with is the
lack of their willingness to step to the
plate to help solve the problem so why
are they looking to the government to
solve their problem when they could be
doing more of this on their own and
helping you out directly to solve
something that they will truly benefit
from ultimately we all do because if the
economy goes up we all benefit from it
but directly it's the employee that
benefits from being employed but more
importantly it's the employer benefits
from the employee being there in the
first place because I keep hearing time
and time again
we can't grow our business because we
can't find the workers
and I think that's exactly right
why we're looking at some of these
initiatives to move forward and having
that conversation looking at the models
looking at how can we ensure that the
business Community is at the table
helping us solve the problems that we
have
and I agree 100 I am you know I run a
center I am I'm in charge of a small
business I agree it's responsibility on
the the onus is on businesses
however in order to build those
relationships we might need the support
of the State of New Hampshire and we
might need the strength of the State of
New Hampshire to help us work this out
in addition the child care Staffing
crisis is so significant and it is
getting worse every day this is not
something we've been able to turn around
we have staff continuing to leave we
have programs continuing to close so in
in the short term if we do not retain
and recruit some staffing we will not
exist for these relationships with
businesses it is it is a dying industry
in New Hampshire
representative King
so this is a kind of encouraging and
somewhat puzzling at the same time
um so the questions that have come out
about the business
I I I agree that the businesses
shouldn't be creating child care
centers but is but they it seems like we
need to Rally the businesses together
across the state and and
see how they can actually support you in
creating the centers that their
employees need is is there a plan is
that what this plan is
I don't know if that's directly
approached in this plan but it is
something that we're looking at and you
know some of the things that have been
spoken about in our wages group are
things like how many llc's are there in
New Hampshire can there be an increase
in the LLC
um
fees every year to go towards Child Care
is there a really logical thing that we
are missing that's a way for the a very
direct way for business people to
support the child care industry because
you're right they do need us so
um I think we need guidance for that I
think we need help and I think we're
really just on the tip of the iceberg
about the way this will look at New
Hampshire
could I just ask what llc's are
limited liability oh okay
why LLCs as opposed to all other
corporations I honestly it's just the
first thing that came up came into my
mind oh yeah we're looking at all of
those corporations it's a different
business model and usually what an LLC
is it made no sense in the context of
the sentence I'm sorry
yeah and I think that you know where
we're initiating conversations with
other entities that do support the
business Community such as the business
Finance Authority the Community
Development Finance Authority so having
these conversations with them as well as
non-profit organizations it's going to
take I think a lot of support in from a
lot of different angles so we're really
at the beginning of
pursuing these kinds of changes
representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman
um been a lot of discussion about
facilitating licensing processes for
various professions has that does that
affect this and has that been in any
kind of way an impediment to um Child
Care problem or cause of it
um it like every other piece of this pie
it it does affect it and so I always I
always think of a child care licensing
in our licensing regulations their
safety regulations that exist but
um we're so over regulated there's over
a thousand of them so no human being
could have possibly know all of them and
they do chip away at how much it costs
for us to do business so someone might
eat something on a playground like might
need a rock on a playground and all of a
sudden we're Banning rocks on
playgrounds and then you have to hire
someone to get all the Rocks off your
playground so yes I think regulations do
affect us I don't think I think the
majority of them are health and safety
related and truly should be there to
support families and to know that
they're getting safe care but I do I do
agree that our licensing regulations are
worth looking at have you had a chat
recently with Lindsey Courtney and oplc
on this
um is I'm sorry is that the office of
professional licensure and certification
I personally have not we we tend the
last legis
lative advisory Council in early
learning New Hampshire attended the last
group of the special committee to look
at child care rules and regulations and
they were asking us about our opinions
on child care licensing also so yeah I
was there I think I asked yes yes yes
yes I'm sorry so yes I I
patients came out because we wanted to
give child care providers a real chance
to have an honest conversation about the
things that were working and the things
that weren't and we did create a list of
recommendations from that some of which
were adopted some of which were not
I just want to add that so the
Department's child care licensing unit
is the unit that administers and
oversees monitors licensed child care
providers
um
so that that's the the
yeah it's not opl it's not polc for you
folks okay
just just for clarification well I
appreciate that she's got enough to do
right now and they are wonderful people
I think they truly have the best
interest of children at heart but it's
really easy to it's I think it's always
easy to create a rule when maybe there
doesn't need to be one
it is it the case now or are you
considering the case that
oplc is looking at that if you're fully
licensed and have no negatives against
you on your record in another state and
you move here it's going to be much
easier going forward to license you hear
hi
so for the Department oh sorry it wasn't
on um Melissa stains here I'm the chief
lead officer for the department and I
oversee the Bureau of Licensing and
certification which includes child care
licensing
our child care licensing is it really
has to do with the The Entity the
program not the individuals the
individuals have to pass background
checks but they aren't actually licensed
child care workers in those spaces
that's why the office of professional
licensure is not involved it's
specifically just the business that that
retains the license
if that's helpful that's very helpful
thank you
thank you representative Merchant
thank you Mr
in your opinion
given the fact a lot of this is through
regulation and through legislative
activity
do you have any recommendations to the
legislature itself on things that we
could do to change either to improve
your retention of employees
um things that were creating a barrier
to you having employees or the industry
itself I mean a lot of it is how do we
somehow work collaboratively
with you folks and if you have any
recommendations on how we can do that
I wish I had a better answer but it's
really Financial so the states that have
increased their retention and
recruitment have increased the wages of
child care workers usually through some
sort of State intervention so I can give
an example Maine our wages group is
spoken to DHHS and Maine several times
and what they've done is they've created
a system where child individual child
care providers so my staff will invoice
monthly and they'll receive a 200
stipend from the state to stay in child
care and the retention rates have been
much higher on the unfortunate part of
that though is that New Hampshire
providers can now move to Maine and take
advantage of that so they're they're
Innovative thoughts have decreased our
Workforce
follow-up
how is that funded in the state of Maine
is it funded through
the business Community providing funding
to support that or is it somehow through
another word which we don't like to use
around here called taxes
the Assumption was that there would be
more federal dollars coming to support
child care because there have been many
federal child care bills that have not
really gone anywhere but when this was
created I'm assuming they were starting
to create their pathway when War federal
funds were available unfortunately we
have not heard any more about federal
funds being available to support child
care at least Beyond Child Care
ccdf the state scholarship funds
do you know of other states that have
worked directly with the business
Community to have the business Community
underwrite the cost of this versus it
going directly through a taxation
process
um unfortunately it has gone through a
taxation process primarily Massachusetts
and Vermont both have taxation processes
in Philadelphia they they enacted a
sweetened beverage tax and so for every
Coca-Cola or every I don't know Diet
Pepsi that you buy
um there was a one cent tax on that it's
created so much revenue that
um it's more than what the early
childhood education system thought they
would need to to fund their system and
the rest of it goes back into the
general budget for Philadelphia
thank you
representative McDonald
getting back along that same vein and
this may not be a fair question so I
apologize if it isn't but
um
you've made reference to the fact that
Target pays as much or more Dunkin
Donuts pays as much or more what kind of
our child care workers they're paid by
the hour or by salary is it an hourly
wage go ahead
usually hourly
like some management probably or salary
but it's usually hourly I can tell you
that at my agency the average teacher
salary is 16.79 an hour I'm a non-profit
I have Diversified funding and I have
tried my darndest to raise it higher
than that and I just cannot follow up
what kind of hourly wage are we looking
at to
you know make it not just better but
I mean I know that the optimum bid might
be a tough one that actually is an
excellent question because we are
looking at in our group wages group
we're looking at different wage scales I
think a lot of people want to equate
child care with the public education
system that's apples and oranges it
really doesn't work our days are longer
our years are longer
um I can understand the Symmetry but it
really doesn't work we are looking at
lnas we're looking at the nursing
profession as being Equitable as far as
education is concerned and as far as
advancement is concerned and the steps
you have to go through to advance and in
those cases the the living way I I'm
going to give you a ballpark figure I
would love it if my my 1679 was closer
to 22 23 dollars an hour sorry about
twenty three dollars that would be yes
the optimum I guess yeah I I mean it's
expensive to live in New Hampshire and
when you raise wages it not only raises
wages it makes it livable but it also um
increases quality the people that would
apply are going to be of higher quality
thank you
I am
on the special committee on child care
but because of scheduled conflicts I'm
not participating as much as I
want to and need to so maybe this is a
question I should ask the chairman Ross
Barry but I'm hearing
parallel paths here how do you see the
value of the special committee on child
care as speaking into this issue
what I'm hoping
that's that because Child Care is such a
problem there are a billion Child Care
bills and I think that it's truly one of
those industries that everybody thinks
they can solve and I'm hoping the
special commitment committee will look
at all of those bills and really sort of
find a pathway through there's I mean we
had situations where something was
introduced in the Senate but it was very
close to something that was introduced
in the house I mean that's not a good
use of people's time and that's not a
good use of your time so we're hoping
that it helps streamline the process so
we really can get to a solution
thank you I can see that division of
labor but collaborative working yeah
yeah thank you I just wanted to also
respond a little bit to the question
about uh support from the legislature in
the child care strengthening plan on the
last page there are a couple of items
identified there that really speak more
to policy than they do the funding well
I agree with Miss barter that funding
and that kind of support financial
support for the child care industry is
absolutely necessary so that low-income
families have access to child care and
that we have an equitable system but the
couple of items I just wanted to bring
to your attention are on that last page
and one of them relates to having
Statewide standards for health and
safety codes for child care that would
be quite beneficial
for
for the industry for various providers
because they're quite inconsistent
across the state and that's been
challenging the other one is
property tax exemptions for providers as
well or Facility Owners on the condition
that the tax credit is passed on to
providers who are tenants so just a
couple of items there for consideration
and I'm sure that Ms barter and I would
be more than happy to talk further about
any of those
representative Weber
my apologies for having to step out uh
so this may have gone over but it
sounded like there was it relates to the
tale of the conversation we were having
when I came in and I did recall where I
heard the suggestion about
um
paying for people's education a month at
a time
so that it's Equitable for everybody and
it does provide this the incentive to
stay it was in the context of a
discussion uh about workers at a similar
level for the Council on Aging
where
home care workers are needed and the
other thing that came up loud and clear
is of course we are a long and very
skinny State and we have a lot of other
states around the edges and despite the
fact that all of those other states have
income taxes in most cases people are
better off going to Massachusetts
Vermont or Maine and paying their income
tax
than they are staying in New Hampshire
and taking advantage of the New
Hampshire Advantage so I think that
that's something for us as policy makers
to think about long and hard I realize
that's not anything you can do anything
about but I think it's
certainly coming from the southwestern
corner it's a real issue for everybody
seeking workers in my part of the
country
and I'm sorry I didn't bring the
statistics for this but it is true that
we in New Hampshire we pay less for
child care we pay less Child Care wages
than other states so yes you can go to
any of our surrounding states and you
will make more working in child care
representative Edwards I I was just
curious if I I just heard the uh the
gentle lady on the other end of the
table suggests New Hampshire Implement
an income tax I hope you didn't
in 2006 I ran on that and I would vote
on it again but the fact is that I know
I'm not going to get anywhere so I
decided to pick my battles but yes
proud
member of the delegation from the
People's Republic of Cheshire
as a non-coca-cola drinker I do
favor the one cent per bottle
fee
I drink both
um we have done research on this a very
extensive study was done in 2016 and the
estimated revenue from this tax would be
about 50 million dollars for the State
of New Hampshire do you think that
drinking Coke and not Diet Coke would
put a burden on Mr lippman in the dental
program
sorry but
assistance and child care scholarship
and and food stamps so right now we're
we're already funding Child Care an
awful lot if we can get them to a living
wage we won't have to do that
Mr chair yes you cited sort of a study
or something back in 2016. is there some
place that we can find that or could you
forward it to us
certainly um and it was a actually the
Department of Health the DHHS Department
of Health that's completed that work but
I would be happy to forward it to you
thank you
representative Weber from the Republic
of Cheshire
and and just one more word from the
Republic of Cheshire if we were to
Institute an income tax we would not
only have our income tax but we would
have a credit against the income tax
paid to other people so we would have
all of the income tax that's sucking its
way out of New Hampshire as well
could we have a compromise that only
Cheshire county would have an income tax
Mr chair I have other meetings that I'm
avoiding because I'm here and I would
like to get this conversation back to
health and human services instead of on
an income tax thank you Mr chair
anyone else
okay
thank you so much thank you so much
and
foreign
from developmental service read design
implementation status update or the
acronym
I'm Melissa Hardy I'm the director for
the division of long-term supports and
services
hi good morning I'm Sandy pharaohs I'm
the bureau chief at the Bureau of
Developmental services
so we were asked to provide and I think
this is going to be a monthly update as
far as the BDS systems work goes in
relation to some of the legislation that
was
brought up this session so we're happy
to take any feedback or if you want
further information that wasn't
presented today please let us know and
we can provide that for you but wanted
to
um start off kind of with a baseline of
what the redesign implementation status
is currently and what we're looking to
do moving forward
thank you
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair so it's stated today uh is has
this gone to cisney has it been
coordinated with cisney at all
um this this presentation this this
project there's a project plan in here
that's pretty specific it's the first
time I've seen that yes this has been
shared with cisney this has been shared
um with our advisory committee so um in
our provider Network so all of these
um slides that are in here have been
presented in other meetings Okay so even
though this is dated today that just
means you tailored it for this committee
exactly uh could I get a soft copy of
this yes okay
and has this been prepared in light of
the three bills that um Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
looked at with in the last few weeks yes
okay
Disney stands for csni Community Support
Network Incorporated which is the
representative group for the 10 area
agencies
representative Weber
and as one who is in the health and
human services and elderly Affairs
committee how about the quality control
Council
um yeah the quality control Council um I
don't think we've I don't know if we had
a meeting since
um the hearing
um and now but um there are we certainly
I'm asking has this been shared oh uh
not yet not yet no okay but we can send
it out to all of our stakeholders um
some of the folks that are on the
quality Council are also on our advisory
committees so some of them have seen it
but not directly with the quality
Council itself
was that was one of our focuses so I
want to keep our eye on that absolutely
representative Edwards uh thank you
again Mr chair so the representative who
was working on hb608 trying to
coordinate you know what a uh a project
plan a pilot project might look like I I
think I heard her in the hallway as we
passed saying that the discussions is
around the pilot project had essentially
collapsed and really didn't produce
anything that people could agree to is
um what what what what's your
perspective of it whether or not that
process may have triggered
thoughts from the on the department side
relative to
implementing or putting together a pilot
project that hadn't already been
envisioned did was that a complete waste
of time the 608 or or did some good come
out of that
that's why Mr Williams got out there
your lawyer up yeah I would say I
wouldn't say it was a complete waste of
time now I I do think having those
conversations with Disney with the area
agencies with the providers to start and
to continue the conversations about our
two tracks you know our compliance
deadline
plan but also the piloting of additional
services and rates in the future I think
it was a good opportunity to start and
continue to have those conversations on
the books
follow up so so since you got something
out of it
is that is that bill worthwhile at all
at this point is it it's you it's become
overcome by events because you all are
already now actively planning and
communicating and working together yeah
yeah I would say that for I don't think
what was in that legislation needed to
be legislated I think it needed to
prompt and open up the discussions
between all of the stakeholders that are
a part of that and I think that did
support that conversation
um I do think there is still some
disagreement even within the stakeholder
Community about you know when and who
and where things should be piloted we've
been within their own organizations but
I think it it sparked more conversation
right one one more follow-up and then
hold on
um okay so it every time we have an
opportunity in this committee to talk
about the the DD Community we talk about
the DD wait list and we keep getting
reminded that we're required by law to
fully fund the DD wait list and so it's
it's become routine to report that we
have no wait list because it's fully
funded to which the counter request is
routinely
can you give us some data on what the
real wait list is then how many people
are standing around or doing whatever
living their lives needing services that
we know just aren't able to get it from
the lack of providers or whatever right
do we do we have a Graphic that we can
track routinely yeah so we don't have
that here today because I believe we're
reporting on the wait list numbers in
April but we are instead of just coming
and saying you know everyone's fully
funded there's no wait list we have
broken it down into people who have
funding but have not started services or
people who have have their funding and
started partial services so you'll see I
think we did that the last time we
reported out on the wait list kind of
broke it down into those categories so
it wasn't just about the funding piece
it was about who was receiving full or
partial services and why or why not
I'm so excited by that thank you the
geek in me is happy
and represent chairman Pearson if I
could just um uh address the initial
questions and my presence here I uh for
the record John Williams I'm the
director of legislative affairs so I'm
here solely in my capacity as the
director for legislative affairs and I
can't improve upon what director Harding
has provided the committee I did uh the
reason why I did come up was I was
actually personally involved in working
with representative Leon who spent some
quality time with the Department to
going over a proposal that we thought
was a very thoughtful approach to
address the underlying goals of the bill
I I think that ultimately uh
participating in the gallery watching
the vote into discussions as it related
specifically to HB 608 that the
recommendation to retain that bill and
then to have this matter heard before
this August committee was a very good
approach to building on the goal of
increased communication between all the
important stakeholders in the department
and that concludes my commentary thank
you representative Weber and I just
wanted to add to that that 608 was
retained and it was retained not with
the intent of killing it but with the
intent of
it it became clear to us that
that was a longer time frame than the
compliance part of the puzzle but that
this was a retention that we really
wanted to hold on and I think I won't
speak for anybody else on the committee
but my sense was that uh we're all
committed to keep on looking at that and
pursuing it and that we have a vehicle
for quick action in early January if
quick action is needed and if it is just
a Spur to action that doesn't require
legislative
action so much the better but I don't
think it's I don't think it's either
collapsed or being abandoned
thank you for that I didn't have all
that status and that's that's good to
know thanks
but thank you so I'm on the second page
of your handout is just
um a an ongoing uh Milestone and kind of
timeline of our doings in BDS as it
relates to the systems work so you can
see the the dark line
um as of July 1 that's our compliance
date for our corrective action plan for
CMS and so I just wanted to provide you
know what's happening leading up to that
compliance state of 7-1 and then post
seven one what our plans tentatively are
and this is always a moving Target based
on it our input from our stakeholders
that are in our advisory groups but just
wanted to provide an overall timeline
any questions on the timeline
representative King
I'm not sure exactly how to ask this but
um
so I see the timeline and I see a lot of
things have been going on before today
um and
is what you're about to present a lot of
um like uh the outcomes of the project
and what happened before today yes I
would say uh we'll talk about some of
our Key activities as it leads up to our
compliance State and how we're engaging
our providers to be ready for that
compliance State and then how we're
going to move forward with the
stakeholders and developing after that
compliance date what a pilot program
would look like as far as the
recommendations that were made in the a
m report
representative Weber
and I would be remiss if I didn't note
again the concerns that I'm hearing
regularly from my
area providers not the service direct
service providers but the the now
indirect service providers about how the
compliance is going to be implemented
and how on Earth they're going to
implement it when they still don't know
what it is exactly that they're
implementing and we're almost to April
so I just I just put that forward again
no I appreciate that I guess my my
question is how are you going to
communicate with them in a meaningful
way so that they can get their ducks in
a row exactly um so I think a little bit
further along in the presentation no no
it's fine
yeah no we
um you know our work leading up to now
has really been focused on creating the
area agency
um rate that they'll get paid for their
administrative costs so now that that
has been solidified with the work with
our stakeholder groups and the area
agencies it's now has been submitted to
CMS for approval
we're now working and spending the
majority of our focus on the actual
provider Network I think on slide or
page six it talks about provider
Readiness and how do we get our
community-based providers ready for the
July 1 transition and then post seven
one
um so we have started implementing and I
think we had one this week we're almost
200 providers
attended an information session where we
were able to have a basic um live q a
with their questions about
um the compliance that they need to uh
participate in for 7-1 so we've started
having those open Office hours will be
every other week for providers to jump
on and ask the department questions and
then we'll have we do have a monthly
provider meeting that has some sort of
review of a policy or a procedure and
then an open q a so we have at least
three formal touch points open to all
providers every month as it relates to
their Readiness for mostly direct bills
a lot of their concerns
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
during the hearing on House Bill 608 one
of the things I heard was
agreement on the what we're trying to
accomplish versus the how
so can you explain
to me at this point in time we're
building
the process we're building the path
is there agreement amongst the
stakeholder community
on the direction and the objective where
we're trying to go in the first place
because if we're not in agreement to
build something
without having that kind of buy-in
I think it's going to be problematic
because then we have to go back and
rework it and when you get into it Mr
Edwards over here representative Edwards
knowing I.T to what he does it's a
significant investment both in time and
money so how do we avoid that
yeah I think again I think it's a it's a
two path
um project right so we have compliance
that we have to to
um achieve by seven one or our you know
Federal funding is
um at Jeopardy so I think anything our
our stance is anything that's
non-compliance related so just services
that we want to enhance on the waiver or
change on the waiver will be part of
that piloting project with the
stakeholders with the area agencies and
providers post seven one so they'll be a
part of Designing developing and
measuring whether those pilot projects
makes sense for long-term use
along with individuals and families that
are actually receiving the services are
these new Services something that is
meeting their needs or is there
something else that we need to think
about as a as a community for
Disabilities that would make
community-based living better for people
with disabilities
follow up
thank you Mr chair when I look at the
timeline
the I.T phase of one and two upgrades go
live on page two
that's clearly in May 23 Which is less
than six weeks away
so I'm really concerned I hear what
you're saying but I'm concerned about
having that buy-in
that we actually have it are we still
working on the buy-in before we design
phase one and two so I'll say
one for this
with our department we
you know have a really Antiquated I.T
system a lot of our
um you know payments to Providers are
still done a manual process and then
pushing through a system so the first it
update is really to automate some of the
like we have we have a functional screen
which is part of our assessment of
um of people coming into the system so
that's going to be something that's
automated I think
in developing that functional screen
process we do have buy-in from our
stakeholders we had subcommittees
working on you know does this make sense
we've had our contractor Deloitte who
does our I.T work show
our providers and our stakeholders what
it would look like in the new system so
as we are developing these different
phases we are including the stakeholders
in those decisions and showing them
physically you know what Deloitte is
doing to create that I.T system so
that's really the first upgrade that you
see in the spring would be the
functional screen and some automation of
reporting to representative Edwards
comment earlier about coming to this
committee and Reporting on more service
level as far as the wait list we do all
of that manually with the area agencies
to count
people who are funded and are not so
we're looking in conjunction with the
area agencies and the stakeholders what
makes sense to put in something that's
automated where we're not writing
counting you know numbers of people and
then reporting out
thank you
anything further
hmm
I don't think so I think he goes into
that question we'll see you next month
thank you all right thank you thank you
hello yes
yes
and now the chair Rec recognizes
representative James
Makai in the Old Country McKay here
and he he had asked if he could speak
about something he'd like us uh perhaps
to consider doing thank you Mr chairman
uh and to the discussion we've had so
far today is extremely pertinent in
terms of what's on my mind
it's not well known that the oversight
committee has the authority and
responsibility to form its own
committees
and has done so in fact the chairman has
been chair of at least two that I know
of them
so I'm
advocating that we use that
responsibility when we particularly hear
about issues that that are chronic that
I've been here for a long time and I've
heard about DD issues all of those years
so more than 20
the other day we had a presentation in
front of the health committee
and it was painful to sit there and
listen
and watch the the pain that was going on
between the people who provide the
services and who pay for it
and the fact that they cannot
communicate with each other
and Charlie McMahon and I have been
working on this for uh God only knows
the DD wait list was a major issue for
years
so so what I'm suggesting is that the
oversight committee used that Authority
it's a form subcommittees we have people
in the communities who are willing and
able to participate
in this including people who have
formally been in the legislature and
maybe for no reasons of their own are no
longer here
the other one that the DD one struck
home more than anything that I can
remember in recent years of a tremendous
amount of pain and and that pain is
shared by the department I'm not saying
that Our intention is to beat somebody
up but it is to get people to
communicate
the other one that keeps coming back
over and over and over again
is the number of people who are sitting
I think they call them borders now the
people who are mentally ill who are
sitting in emergency rooms
and
when I drove over here today it was
announced that there were 30 adults and
I've forgotten the exact number of
children that are in emergency rooms
if they're very illegally because there
were certain things that are supposed to
happen
within so many hours of being in there
so that it isn't to debate those issues
but to say that the legislature has the
authority and responsibility uh to look
into these issues
independently of others and
and I think there are a lot of
individuals who are willing to
participate
in such a venture who have legislative
experience
from the past
it actually is is in the law and for the
life of me of with all the piles of
paper that accumulate I couldn't find
the law that there's very specific as as
to how to proceed
with
and with with what I'm discussing and
I'm very willing to participate in
whatever way would be helpful and I'm
glad to answer any questions
anybody on the uh
oversight committee wished to ask
representative McKay any questions on
his proposals representative Weber
collection of the statute which I have
not yet quickly been able to find is
that somebody wanting to set up a
subcommittee submits in writing and I
see Mr Williams as nodding his head in
the back which reassures me that I'm on
the right track
submits a proposal in writing for what
the committee would do and you know who
what sorts of people would be on it and
the time frame and stuff like that
submits it to the committee and the
committee votes on it I think the thing
although we have the capacity to set up
innumerable subcommittees
the realistic issue is that each of
those committees if I am recalling
correctly must be chaired by a member of
this committee
and given that we have members of this
committee who regularly fail to show up
and that those who do show up are among
the most busy members of the legislature
that I know of that's where the
bottleneck is going to be so I think
having a very specific purpose
and Mission is is going to be critical
we were able to do this I think we
skipped one of these steps we were able
to do this last October with
representative
Solway in terms of precision medicine
and also in terms of uh
uh visibility of
um
Board of Medicine records and we did
this on the quick but those were
committees that met really for about
four or five weeks had a specific
purpose led to some legislation then
Sunset but this
could be done representative Merchant or
senator
uh to comment on the Committees that we
did have I've spoken to the chair before
and we have a charter in this committee
and it does not include Board of
Medicine it does not include a lot of
the other boards that are out there so
we need to make sure that the things
that we do are supported by our Charter
so just a comment you know we don't want
to go too far but Health and Human
Services does have an awful lot of
tentacles and a lot of things so but you
do have to stay within the bounds
who would rule on that Senator as to
whether a proposal is appropriate or not
uh the chair would make an initial uh
ruling whether or not it was and then if
someone on the committee objected then
that would be the committee vote just as
you would in any of the other
committees that you have to overrule the
chair
right
Mr chair yes uh point of
understanding
in regards to representative Weber's
comment about this being chaired by
somebody from this committee
does the person who chairs the committee
have to be in person or could they do
this remotely
I don't believe we have any
authorization to do things remotely at
the moment
for this body
it's it's a body of the legislature
I'll check
I think I know the answer but I'll let
somebody else say no rather than me
saying no but what I'm trying to if you
check on this Mr chair if you would
is the community meeting here but to
representative Weber's point a lot of us
are extremely busy and travel time is
hard so if there's a way to minimize the
travel time so the committee is actually
meeting in person
but the chair doesn't have to be here in
person but just participate or lead the
committee remotely that could help
representative Weber and I'm incorrect
it it's not it doesn't actually state
that it shall be a member of this
committee it's a point of chair of each
such body who shall be a legislator and
who shall act as the liaison between the
body and the oversight committee
does not have to be a member of this
committee and just another silent on
that but it just says who shall be a
legislator it doesn't say who shall be a
member of the committee I think we've
always sort of assumed that having
somebody who is a member of the
committee will provide better liaison
than having somebody not a member of the
committee uh the other reservations are
that they're the authorization for each
such body shall be repealed on December
31st of the even numbered year at the
biennium so it can't extend beyond the
biennium
and um
uh
nope that's different
so it could include a senator
and and the the
well the other point of the
subcommittees is they don't have to be
composed entirely of legislators they
can be composed of one legislator plus
and have in the past plus other
community members who are relevant to
whatever the duties are
and it says
that we may create subcommittees task
forces councils or other ancillary
bodies is necessary to implement our
responsibilities and in developing the
bodies the committee shall take into
account major program areas of the
department and population served by the
department such as public health
Behavioral Health Developmental
Disabilities and elderly and Adult
Services
and so it's very clear that it's tied
specifically to uh the departmental
oversight which is our primary mandate
it's not an inquiry into anything that
impacts Health anywhere it's it's with
relationship to the Department
so those would be the
um guardrails that Senator gray was
talking about
representative Weber what's
the the number you're citing what's the
reference
well as as representative McDonald
showed me it's
126-a colon 15 and it's in our notices
every month when we are noticed
that in there he he noticed that and
slid it over to me which helped greatly
in my researches
I don't know
so representative McKay I'm
open to one or more committees
um would you be able to then submit in
writing a specific proposal that then we
could read send it to me I'll distribute
it around to the committee and
absolutely thank you representative
Edwards
so just one tip on that uh when writing
the purpose statement if you think that
the purpose statement could start to get
subjected to scope creep because there
are so many issues near it
in a purpose statement it's sometimes
useful to say what the committee will
not do sort of to Define you know what
it will do but also a key a few key
things to say what it won't do just so
that everyone understands it's what's in
scope what's not in scope
uh we're all aware of and that have not
been resolved
and that if we have an unusual
opportunity and authority to do
something
and I think that's partly because I've
been here so long I keep seeing the same
things on the same people saying the
same things so that it's a real
opportunity because I think we've seen
because of what the chairman has already
done that it works
representative McKay would you have any
objection if the chair asked
representative Edwards to help you in
crafting these statements so that they'd
be just what we need to see because he's
done these things well before Mr
chairman could I just make an addition
I'm waiting to get a yes and I did yes
representative Weber
the issue with chronic problems is we
have a number of very large chronic
problems and I think that if you're
going to have a subcommittee that
addresses one chronic problem at a time
that is going to be
easier for everybody including the
subcommittee to cope with
um because
um I I agree with representative Edwards
the Committees that we have had that
have subcommittees we've had that have
been very very successful have been just
the opposite of what you're proposing
they have been
a very specialized subcommittee to deal
with a specialized and uh immediate
problem rather than a chronic problem
and that's no way to discourage
the addressing of chronic problems but I
think that I agree with representative
Edwards that the guard rails have to be
particularly careful
with respect to Chronic problems or
people will just be
disseminating more energy than they are
actually solving problems
in spite of the fact that the
subcommittee on transparency was really
had nothing to do with the Department of
Health the Human Services it did focus
on one thing did his business made its
report and away it went that that would
be a limiting and
if that subcommittee is satisfied with
the work that it has done and has issued
its report and done what it wants to do
then it could Sunset it has to Sunset by
the end of our legislative term and
people could
start another one or we could start a
couple and run parallel and whoever
wants to be in could be in but uh yeah
it cannot be we have problems or it
would be all over the map in my opinion
so thank you thank you for coming we've
been discussing this now for a couple of
months and it's it's been we've been
circling around this point and if
representative Edwards would be so kind
to help you draft those statements
get them to me when you're satisfied
with them all disseminated to the group
and we can discuss it at that the
following meeting
I know that representative Edwards has a
few other things
he's on a win streak right now
[Music]
right that's still valid
HHS yes
anything else from the committee
saying none thank you we're adjourned
we've got 20 minutes to spare
well let's keep talking
I was going to go up there late and ask
them to move